all right guys
bang bang i have nicole here with me
thank you so much for doing this
thanks for having me all right let's
just jump right into your background
somehow people know you as a comedian
and like 10 other things what what do
you do every day and what is your
background
uh well i am a comedian that's my main
thing that everybody knows about me
um people call me a digital renegade and
i kind of ran with it what does that
mean
that means i can make [ __ ] go viral it
means
i like to tinker with products and work
on dev teams and beta teams in advance
to make sure [ __ ] goes viral um yeah and
i'm a nerd when it comes to all things
digital and
absolutely love it analytics kind of
like get me all tingly
okay before before you became a digital
renegade what were you doing
um comedy it was so yeah i was just
straight up comedy except i was working
in marketing a bunch too because
i was hired as a comic years ago for a
molson canadian
giant campaign and i was the host of
this cross canada tour
i went into their marketing meeting with
the president of the whole company and
everyone on their marketing team they
told me what i had to say in the
commercial and what was going to go on
and i didn't know i wasn't supposed to
tell them it sucks
and i was just like no this is really
bad you guys sound like a bunch of
late 40s people trying to sound like
you're in college the terminology you're
using the lingo is like
four years old i'm not saying any of
this you're gonna kill my brand
and there's like what would you do
and i told them and then it went viral
before viral was viral
and then that campaign led to a campaign
with virgin mobile helping launch it in
canada
led to working with nike and unilever
and axe products helping launch them and
i was just a comic that ended up good at
marketing
all right so how much of the experience
and knowledge of being a comic and and
people forget like that is a skill and
that is something that you can kind of
hone your craft with is dependent
or is necessary to understand how the
internet works and how to make content
go viral like do you it does that
experience help or is that just kind of
a coincidence that you have the
comedic experience and also understand
how to make things go viral uh it's 100
together it's timing it's eliciting
emotion from people
the motion doesn't always have to be
laughing but you have to get an emotion
from someone
and fear seems to be doing very well
these days
not a fan of it but it's doing well um
but yeah it's it's super helped because
i've learned
comedy performance in writing i've
learned you know kind of how to
influence people
and that's really what i think it comes
down to and telling the truth comics
tell the truth a lot and people
people like that nets it's literally the
only reason why i like having comedians
come on here is because the comedians
are allowed to say the truth and no one
gets mad because they're told that
you're supposed to laugh at the end
oh no they get mad yeah they've tried to
cancel me like 12 times now
it's just yeah all right let's just talk
about it you did this fat
shaming or like dear fat people video
what was going on there what happened
by the way that video that video has 15
million views on youtube
it has over 100 million views over 100
million okay
walk us through that whole thing yeah
sure i just uh i had been disabled for
most of my 20s after a car accident
and i set out to
basically make all the videos that i
wanted to make say all the things i
wanted to say before i was dead
and i was like i'm going to say these
things because they need to be said
i've been in bed for all these years if
i was going to die tomorrow what do i
want the world to know
and seeing people harm themselves every
frickin day is ridiculous
especially when we pretend we care about
people but then we let them
kill themselves slowly in front of us
it's ridiculous
so i just made that video and i'm like
here's the truth
you're killing yourself and just made it
funny and at the end i edited out a
little part
where i said as someone who's been
disabled for this many years i couldn't
walk
and i all i wanted was a healthy body i
took it out the last second
because i knew that wouldn't make it go
viral they had to hate me
i had to let them hate me so i did and
then
uh every day i get hundreds of messages
still from people that
uh that videos helped them lose
ridiculous amounts of weight
it was the verbal [ __ ] slap that they
needed and that's exactly what i wanted
so where's the line in terms of there's
this like political correct
uh world that exists and everyone you
know has their own opinion as to what
you're supposed to do they want to tell
you what to do and
and basically force their uh views of
the world onto you
versus like the old school mentality of
just like tough love right and i always
like to talk about like most people if
you talk to them
they'll tell you a story about their
mother or their father who like at some
point their life like intervened in a
very serious way
and some people it was like my parents
like spanked me all the way to like
my dad was like we don't do that here
right and so like somewhere in between
like tough love ended up having a
positive impact
that seems to not be so popular now so
like how do you think about the balance
between those two things and what can be
said and what can't be
i feel like with the the lowering of
tough love
the rise of lying has it has been
completely
you know together so i think being
politically correct is just lying with a
bow
it's not what you really think it's not
what you really believe you're saying it
because you think it'll make you popular
and you're a liar
and i was brought up being called out
constantly
by family members by whoever we were
just funny and
tough love is all i knew and without it
without tough love is honesty that's all
it is without that we're all just full
of [ __ ]
so what's the point we can't let people
tell us to stop being honest
because it's not popular that's really
messed up i don't know a single comedian
who doesn't have this like pursuit of
ruthless honesty and that's what
ultimately leads to
all of the emotional uh reactions right
yeah
100 like look at my wall of my favorite
people they just
they all tell the truth it's my wallet
heroes i love them
shoulders staring at me making sure i do
[ __ ] right yeah some of those
aren't people they're inanimate objects
but they still tell the truth barbie is
not inanimate she taught me i could be
anything i want to be
she she was an astronaut and a teacher
and she was a lawyer
and it was the barbie dream house not
the ken dream house she had her [ __ ]
together
and she looked hot so what else how
did you get a billion views on the
internet like what is the secret or when
people come to you and they're like hey
i want to be a content creator i want to
make things go viral where do they start
and i'm not talking about like
the actual like secret sauce of each
individual video for
a client or something like that but just
like from a holistic standpoint
what are the keys to that that you think
you understand that other people are
just missing
stop acting everyone can see through
your [ __ ] it's weird
the the hey guys like if that's not how
you talk
why are you doing that now why do you
think you're gonna stand out when you're
trying to act like everybody else
it's just dumb and i see it with brands
too brands are
constantly playing it safe constantly
worried about
what are they going to say what's my
competition going to say it's like why
do you care
and you know it's just like athletes
swing to hit it out of the park or why
are you playing
and people have to be ready for that and
you have to be ready
if you're going to make a viral video
people are going to love it they're
going to hate it
and if you can't deal with both of those
then you're in the wrong business
well it's almost like the controversial
nature of it
right the fact that some people do love
it some people do hate it that
especially on social media drives
more engagement which drives more
virality and you almost have to be
willing to have the downside in order to
get the upside
sometimes like it doesn't have to be a
negative video
to go viral it can be happy i i had one
go viral that it was me and an old lady
unboxing sex toys for adam and eve sex
toy company
i was told you can't make a sex toy
video
like that's like the only thing that you
can't make it go viral it's not going to
happen
it's going to get flagged and taken down
i'm like not if i get a sweet 87 year
old jewish lady to do an unboxing with
me
did you know her beforehand i had better
ones yeah it was my friend's mom
and okay so you've got your friend's mom
to do a
sex toy unboxing video with you and
when do you just like text her and like
hey i have an idea or like how does that
come about yeah
yeah i told her we're gonna do an
unboxing video and it's gonna be a lot
of fun
and she came over and sat on my couch
with me
and i didn't tell her what was in the
box and that's it
and then we just went through shot the
whole thing and at first she was a lot
of like oh
oh oh my and then eventually she's like
grabbing at the toy she's like what's
this one do
i'm like she asked if she could take a
couple things home
yeah but she doesn't like like the thong
bodysuits she's not into that
yeah when i there was like a magic wand
that came out in the one box and
i put it on her back at one point she
was like uh
mile yeah it was great okay
i could i could only imagine an 87 year
old woman going through this and like
all the things going on her head that
she doesn't say out loud but then there
is this element of like older people
kind of just don't care anymore
right so they just say what they want to
say yeah it's the oh they're the best
the best all right so one being honest
what else in terms of
like standing out on the internet going
viral creating content that people
actually care about
it's the same as comedy you have to have
an angle what is it you think about
this thing so it's like water do you
love it do you hate it do we need more
of it do we need less
if you're not saying anything then be
quiet or
find find a reason to speak it shouldn't
just be content for the sake of content
it should be content because you have
something to say
or a message to convey and when you go
from there
what is the message and you make sure
you hit that over and over
that's step two and so how does that
balance with you know there's some
people who just say like hey it's the
consistency of content you have to
constantly crank out content
uh there's a lot of people who don't
have an idea every day or every week
how do you balance those two things
between like only do it if it's high
quality you have something to say with
the need for consistency to remain
relevant and kind of keep growing the
audiences and things like that
um i disagree with the you have to be
posting every single day something every
day
those people that are doing that are
creating content because they're
repurposing talks that they're doing
they're re-purposing
zoom calls that should be meetings that
is actual high quality content
um people who are just posting for the
sake of posting you can see it and it's
trash
and it's like if you're feeding your
audience trash most of the time they're
not going to pay attention
when you're posting something quality so
i think you end up losing more people
than keeping them that way
what platforms do you focus on now is it
youtube
are there other platforms that you think
are worth spending more time on than
others
youtube i stopped posting regularly on a
couple years ago
i was one of the first people on the
facebook monetization program and it
slaughtered it was a good time
um so i was facebook strong for a while
now i'm mostly on instagram and i am
monetized on there same as youtube which
is sweet
uh so i like instagram parlor right now
is crushing
the reach on parlor is i posted the same
video on parlor
got no same video on instagram 200 000
views with my audience of 1.3 million
exact same video got 1.6 million views
on parlor
and i was like there we go what is that
what is the size of your audience on
parlor
uh around 61 000 right now i just
started
and and his parlor got some of the same
algorithmic advantages that like let's
say a tick tock has where
anyone can kind of build an audience
quickly and get distribution or is it
much more aligned to facebook and
instagram twitter something like that
i think it's a mashup of all of it right
now um
i haven't seen that it's easy to be
discovered on parlor but what i am
seeing is that the reach
if i have 61 000 people following me
this is going to go to 61 000 people
so if i'm making something good they're
going to share it and then it's going to
get to all their people
so it's it's that ability they're not
hindering anyone's reach right now it's
just sweet
when you create content how much of it
is like i'm going to create a video to
go on parlor i'm going to create a video
to go on instagram or
tick tock or youtube or wherever versus
i'm going to create a great video
and then i'm going to cut it into
different formats for these various
platforms
i just make it and then post it
everywhere
yep okay how do you monetize in terms of
not like take out the consulting and the
brand work stuff but for you personally
if you were just a creator
how do you monetize and where have you
seen kind of uh the greatest growth in
that monetization the last couple years
brand deals so you know finding partners
that work for your brand and doing
package deals so i'm gonna do
this many videos with you or this many
posts with you um obviously monetizing
just your views on facebook instagram
youtube
all the regular stuff like that but i
see brand partnerships as
my favorite way to do it yeah okay and
so you keep mentioning like instagram
monetization
explain to people what exactly you're
monetizing there and how that works
yeah it's the exact same as youtube so
uh if you get a big enough following and
they like your content
instagram will come to you and say
you're approved for our monetization
program and it's the exact same as
youtube i'm getting paid for views
and watch time the exact same way that i
would on facebook
got and are they running ads in front of
your videos or they're just paying you
for the content basically and then
they're figuring out other ways to
monetize because people are staying on
the platform
i've seen both so i've seen some ads
coming and i kind of think a few more
ads went into my feed they didn't
specify that with me
i just realized that all of a sudden i'm
monetized and money's coming in not mad
at it
yeah got it and when you think of when
you were monetizing on youtube
versus instagram now uh was it pretty
equal in terms of
uh cpm rates and um kind of the size of
the audiences or do you see a pretty big
difference
huge difference facebook and you know
byproduct of instagram
bigger reach bigger dollars higher cpm
everything there has been bigger for me
during the last five years
and youtube of course their algorithm
crushes adult content a lot or comedic
content
um yeah i've just seen a way better
return on facebook
got it and so when you create a video
for facebook or instagram talk us
through like
what exactly goes into that video are
you cutting these into
you know one two minute videos are these
more like 10 20 minute videos and then
the different styles are you just
basically sitting down and recording it
or you going back and like almost doing
like the vlog style cut where there's
just cut after cut after cut in the
video
okay it's different every time so for
example
two days ago i had my camera people come
over and i was like i'm gonna shoot
something i was like i'm gonna buy a
gingerbread house
all right oh i have this like 50s outfit
i'm gonna put that on okay we're gonna
do a
kitchen thing roll your camera that's it
that's all we did i said shoot we shot
for 15 minutes
uh it was a you know a tutorial on how
to make a gingerbread small business
and i think it's like half a million
views so far which is great
today and i just shot it i just improved
and just
shot and it is what it is if i have a
very specific message
i'll sit down and you know shoot
probably like 45 minutes i have to
tighten it up because i don't want to
edit all that after anymore and then
just edit from there all right and one
of the biggest questions i always get
from people is
uh when you're successful on the
platforms with content and
uh monetization how big is the team and
team can be
what you think of as like direct
employees that you have
or it could even be contractors and kind
of people you'll pull in for a video
like that
yeah so i got a one billion views with
just my iphone
and my macbook and a single ring light
that cost me 200
so every time people are like oh i don't
have a team i'm like yeah i was
physically disabled on disability
shooting videos like this and then ended
up on the view so
enough with your excuses anyways uh
now it's easier for me to have a video
person come in so that's like
i like to keep it small one video person
i already have the lights
and then hair and makeup person the end
uh sometimes i'll tag in an editor for a
first sweep but i always do the comedy
stuff
and then yeah keep it tight you don't
need a billion people
and so that was gonna be one of my
questions is basically you'll do a lot
of the editing in terms of the
the final product that people see out on
a platform that's basically you've
you know kind of blessed and before it
went out the door you actually went and
edited it and made sure it was what you
wanted
i completely edit myself 99.9 percent of
my content
uh the odd time i'll have someone do
just the first sweep to take out my um's
eyes
pauses while i'm switching a costume but
everything that goes out i've edited
got it and so we've everything we've
talked about is like ad
type monetization uh or platform based
are you
doing merchandise physical products like
anything else in terms of driving
monetization uh
while using trying to figure out how to
make money off of the views
uh next year i'm doing more of that but
every time i've done merch
it sold out quickly and i was like oh i
should put more time into this but i was
busy over here
um and then go team academy absolutely
crushed which was sweet
it's uh basically my get happy
learn business get your [ __ ] together
get your life together
uh partnered with danelle delgado that a
lot of people know is like the
millionaire maker featured in forbes and
all the magazines
and yeah we did an academy for people
eight week program
ran it twice and it crashed it was great
their lives are just like very different
now so it makes me happy
that's awesome uh i want to switch gears
when you tell the truth it obviously
brings all sorts of controversy and
uh very polarized audiences uh one of
the things that's fascinating to me
about you
is you were a lifelong democrat and then
hung out with a bunch of trump people
and then became pro-trump republican et
cetera
that violates a lot of people's view of
like what's allowed in the world
uh right that you could change your mind
that's a shocking idea
talk us through kind of your upbringing
and kind of political leanings and then
kind of what you did
to uh eventually end up on the other
side
of a lot of those political beliefs yeah
sure so i'm from canada
and i've always been a liberal in canada
i was part of the
parliamentary process kind of stuff in
high school my first
main real person job was junior prime
minister of canada
working for the federal government which
was pretty dope
and then by working at our mp and mpp's
offices which is kind of like senators
i realized that most of them are full of
[ __ ] and
exactly what they say they live the
exact opposite
so instead of taking a scholarship for
political science i decided to be a
comedian
which is i thought it was about the same
um
and then for years i'm just like yeah
i'm i'm a liberal obviously i believe in
liberal things and you know
equal rights for gay people and women's
you know choice on their body and
all the things i thought were good
people choices and these are bad people
over here
and then after the last election
um i've told the story before but i was
speaking right before the last election
at usc
two days before the election and some
people from hillary clinton's camp
came up to me and told me that i'm going
to tell the students that i'm voting for
hillary
they didn't ask me they told me and i
was like no
i'm from canada i'm here to talk about
social media and how it's affecting the
election
and when i was on stage the people i
told no to
got on the mic and said yeah you know
nicole was just backstage saying that
she would vote for hillary if she could
and i was just like [ __ ] you guys like
no i didn't say that and that was like
my first little including in my head
and then after that um i had run down to
texas
where i was just like these people are
crazy they have guns everywhere they got
dogs in the office
they believe they got trump flags i'm
like these people are nuts but let's go
on a field trip
and they're ready to roll they are ready
to roll in taxes
they're ready to roll all the time but
while i was in texas
um just at a bar that i was at i saw
someone push
a little gay twink and then one of these
huge texan guys walked up to the dude
who did it and grabbed him and he's like
we don't do that round here and pushed
him and he was like you okay
little d lady sir man it was like
the funniest [ __ ] i'd ever seen and i
was like oh
okay so they're not all homophobic crazy
people that just want to shoot everyone
predominantly a lot of them are former
or current military
who have a superhero complex in a great
way that they'll run towards danger if
we need it
christian values care about people
they just don't like the [ __ ] and
the more i was
in la where i lived for like five years
the more i saw that
liberals or democrats as we know them
are
the exact opposite of everything they
pretend to be consistently like it
wasn't like once it happened
five times it's every i'd say 99 of the
time
and we're seeing that in politicians now
it's like these are the rules you have
to abide by them i'm eating at french
laundry
you know or like you can't go there i'm
on vacation in cabo
it's like are you a simpsons character
like what is this nonsense
it's part of the playbook it's literally
like to be a politician and to make
mandates you have to go do the opposite
thing i'm convinced there's like a
secret world order where it's like hey
if we shut down restaurants we have to
go to a nice restaurant
if we tell people to stay in their homes
we have to go on vacation like it's a
requirement
yeah that totally makes sense for that
to happen and
just overall i felt like i was living in
idiocracy over there it's like
be kind to everyone [ __ ] that [ __ ] she
can't
i'm like do you hear the music that you
guys are putting out do you see the
films you're putting out why are there
11 year olds doing [ __ ] tick tock
dances and that's cool
don't judge like everything is just
upside down upside down land over there
to me
so i still of course support gay people
and i i support all the same things i
did i just think
to be an honest human being you gotta go
the other way
what was the reaction when people
started to figure this out that you were
doing it
um well actually i learned through dave
rubin that i'm a libertarian
i was like yes this is all of my values
libertarian this makes sense
uh and then right before the election
this time
i was like people people are not paying
attention to china
are we are we really did you guys just
say it's a conspiracy theory what i said
about china and how they've been buying
property around the world for super low
rates and they're basically buying the
whole world
okay you're dumb i gotta go endorse this
side now because if
if trump trump represents to me the ego
and narcissism that is aligned with a
freedom that we require
as americans or north americans if we
want this
we have to think we're better than other
people we have to hold ourselves to a
higher standard
his you know his touches of ego and his
style of doing that
aligns with murca yeah let's go
crying all the time being fake offended
by everything does not align with a
company that's capitalism rich
and has benefited from that and is
kicking ass worldwide because of that
like
it's just too weak so i had to go and be
like yeah
vote for trump it's not that i'm like a
trump supporter i'm like these
ideals make more sense to me i'm not
gonna tell black people who they have to
vote for that's racist
you idiots i'm not gonna you know just
all of the different things that
sit well or don't sit well with me it
went that way and people were fine
like majority of the people were fine
with it how do you think that the
balance between
uh one being willing to go do the work
like there's a lot of people who would
say oh my god that's crazy you're going
to texas like
i hate all those people they're all evil
like i'm not even gonna go so you at
least had like the open-mindedness to
like
go see it you had those experiences like
balancing that with um you know this
belief that like
the way that you grow up is the way that
uh those are your values those are the
things that like for your entire life
like your entire identity is tied to
them right i think there's a lot of
people who
even if they had the open mindedness to
go and have different experiences
they literally end up tying their
identity it's in their twitter bio right
they're like i'm a democrat or i'm a
republican like they can't
get away from ever thinking about having
their own thoughts or being an
independent thinker
how did you do that or how do you
suggest other people do it
just truth just follow the truth it's
it's kind of like the first lesson we're
taught when we're kids is don't lie and
of course as human beings we all do it
to you know not hurt feelings or to not
go to jail whatever
hillary um yeah but it's just i follow
the truth and if something's going on
and i'm like my spider senses are
tingling
this doesn't feel right i need to
research it i'll go watch it on
you know the the different political
stations that aren't edited
i'll watch a full video myself i called
out jimmy kimmel a couple months ago
for running a completely fake story
about mike pence that he knew was fake
all i had to do was go find the full
clip to see that mike pence wasn't
moving fake empty boxes of charity food
or and ppe it was a lie but he ran the
story anyway
and once i saw people doing that i'm
just like yeah i don't really care what
people think
i got to be a real person and my
integrity matters more to me
than making people happy so this brings
up a really interesting thing where
there's like
this blind belief historically in media
journalism you know these large
institutions like they're going to tell
us the truth they're going to do the
work they're you know these honorable
people
uh they're unbiased all this kind of
stuff right i think now we're seeing a
lot of ex
people being supposed it's not everybody
like i think it's always important to
say like there are some really really
good journalists on both sides of
uh the leanings in terms of the
political spectrum but for
many many people they now are losing
trust in these institutions they're
saying hey these individuals
are biased they're actually sometimes
literally lying to us sometimes they're
just twisting facts
to tell a different story whatever so
how do we balance that between like
you have a large platform i have a large
platform and so do they so now like
there's this more like even playing
field where like if you say something i
say something and they say something
like
actually we may reach the same amount of
people and so therefore like
you have a different style of doing it
than i do and then they do
where is like the truth lie and like how
does the audience start to try to
understand like who should i listen to
should i listen to nicole or should i
listen to new york times should i listen
to jimmy kimmel or should i listen to
somebody else like
how did how do they wade through that
um kind of issue turn off mainstream
news turn it off
all of them turn them all off if not
just america if north america turned off
all of their mainstream news
we would all be better period and i've
had to have these chats with my parents
because they watch it they always watch
it it's every night you know six o'clock
news whatever and i'm like mom
you know this isn't real you've seen
them do fake stories about me
you've seen them like run com there was
this narrative that i was fired from the
movie i was never part of this movie i
don't even know these people
uh there was a narrative that i was mean
to this guy in an airplane
they took a bit from my stand up and
pretended it was real and
they like everything is proven wrong i'm
like stop believing them they're liars i
would say
most of them are liars now it's opinion
pieces
and spin stories and i just think that
mainstream media is
just like the national enquirer there is
no difference now
so if you don't believe in bigfoot you
should probably turn off fox and cnn
and then listen to people online is it
because
they have to be entertainment to drive
the ratings like they're losing
viewership
and so you have to be entertaining you
have to elicit those emotions the best
way to elicit emotion is basically scare
the [ __ ] out of people
into thinking like the world's ending so
they tune in tomorrow yeah
100 and i really think with the rise of
online
and the click-through rate and making
money from ads that way
they've tried to click bait us all so if
you keep us terrified and
more later stay tuned we're going to
tell you more later then
they got us it's just a hook for stupid
people so we just have to stop being
dumb be like oh
good game but you know you've just been
cheated on by that boyfriend multiple
times now you're going to keep going
back
what are you doing the the one that just
blew my mind is for six seven eight nine
months whatever it's been now
uh cnn has had the what i call the death
scoreboard
up on cnn right and like by the way like
yes we should address this seriously we
should absolutely take all the steps
that are necessary their science like
everything that people know that we
should do we should do science is great
yeah
but the idea of putting a scoreboard on
cnn every day and literally making
people feel like if they walk out of
their home they're gonna die
just feels like complete fear-mongering
and literally is the definition of like
how do we get people to tune in tomorrow
to check the numbers
yeah 100 i really think
that reporters should be put in prison
for lying or if they're doing something
that they know is fear-mongering and
they're trying
i just think that there should be crimes
against humanity charged on
these media outlets sooner than later
because they know what they're doing
so people who hear that there's gonna be
a lot of people who will immediately say
uh we need freedom by the press we have
to protect people in the press we can't
throw them in jail blah blah blah
that whole argument i'm not gonna go
through the whole thing because people
understand that argument exists
okay you disagree why uh because they're
not reporting
when they were reporting freedom of the
press they're not journalists anymore
they're doing puff opinion pieces and
they're activists i don't care about
your activism you're not giving me facts
if the fact is
you know this many people died or
there's a war in this place and this is
what's going on
freedom of the press but you're lying to
us now and once you lie on purpose i
think that should be a crime
okay so i always use this framework of
uh people in the media basically fall
into one of three categories i'm gonna
put media very very loosely here right
but i usually think of it from a
financial media standpoint but let's
just talk
media in general so there's journalism
these are people who are legitimately
doing journalism they
have a story they go they investigate it
they talk to people on all sides of the
story
they kind of fact check they do all the
things they're supposed to do they write
a
as unbiased a piece as possible they
present all the different
uh viewpoints in the story and they
publish it and then they see what
happens
if there's an issue they correct it they
you know do all the things that a
journalist would do that's one end of
the spectrum on the other end of the
spectrum you have what i call market
participants these are people
in the story right so this is uh
something happens to you you go and you
write a blog piece or you
you know create a video or whatever in
the financial markets it's literally the
investors who are investing in the
markets that when they are
wrong they have skin in the game right
so if you say something and you created
a video
and you're wrong or you're a racist or
you're an [ __ ] or whatever
like there's blowback directly because
you've put your name on that thing yeah
financial markets if you go out and you
say i believe x and you're wrong you
lose money
right like that's the whole point of a
market those are the two kind of extreme
ends but in the middle
and it's an ever-growing middle is what
i call bloggers masquerading as
journalists
these are the people i think you're
talking about which are they essentially
are using blogger tactics they use
clickbait headlines sensationalism etc
but the pieces that they write
are being published under the news
section but it's their personal opinions
there's no they're not talking to
sources they're not going and getting
quotes they're not fact checking
anything it's literally
they wake up and they write a story and
the story is just it's an opinion piece
it's activism it's you know
whatever label you want to put on it but
it doesn't fit into the market
participant bucket because if they're
wrong there's no downside and it doesn't
fit into the journalism side
and to me that's the danger right like
that's kind of like the threat to
american democracy is just we're
allowing things that
are being passed off as journalism but
they're not actually journalism
yes exactly and my favorite game to play
now is
who wrote that so if you see an article
i go and i click on it and i'm like who
wrote that
and i click on them and recently
business insider has been my favorite to
roast because
it will be a student who their only
credits are writing for their student
newspaper and now they're a reporter
for business insider giving completely
fake info about let's say
tesla or whatever and all of the all the
only things they've written are puff
pieces
and if you don't know and respect the
people that are giving you the info
stop reading it the headline who cares
click on who's writing this look at them
if you don't respect that person don't
take their opinion so
how much of it is it's young people
right because this is actually
um a huge piece of it right and pretty
much every
what i'll consider uh true journalist
that i know everyone from my wife
all the way to a number of friends of
ours are actual journalists that
uh their biggest complaint is
so many young people now are running
these places and they don't have
experience they don't have
the you know 30-year veteran there to
say hey
this is the way journalism is done kind
of you just went to journalist school
or literally you were a blogger and then
you got hired somewhere
and now you just keep doing what you've
always done because you don't have
anyone to tell you to do anything
differently and
it feels like it may literally just be
an inexperienced thing that contributes
to the problem as well
somebody spank them they need to be
spanked
this is you know there needs to be some
kind of ramification for their actions
and if no one's holding them accountable
then we need to hold them accountable by
just unfollowing all those accounts
i don't want to see business inside or
if you're going to feed me crap and
you know i don't want to follow fox or
cnn if you guys are going to lie to me
screw you like i almost ripped the
middles but i don't know where this goes
yeah all right like that's how you can
vote on that
so what are those ramifications that you
think are appropriate right
obviously it sounds like you think if
somebody is egregiously lying and it's
like super
bad your position is like hey there's
literally could be crimes jail like
really really bad stuff
i'm assuming that's not what you think
for everybody so like what are the
ramifications or solutions that you
think
could be imposed to try to help solve
this problem
i think make it like sports the first
time you get fined
you know you do something wrong in a
game you get a fine the second time you
get a fine and a flag
and then a third time if you're doing
something that can lead to
let's say someone being assaulted
because you painted them as a racist and
that's not the story
then that is jail time to me if you're
printing that someone did something
awful to another human being and that's
going to affect the rest of their life
that's jail
to me you know that's that's human being
assault whatever it is
but i do think you know first time give
him a warning second time a bigger fine
and a warning and then a third time
if people aren't afraid of going to jail
for what they're doing they're just
going to keep doing it
so all right so do you think fine
fine jail not like fine fine fired
something else and then jail's like the
end of the road you you'd immediately
jump to
the final thing yeah because if you get
fined twice you know what you're doing
i'm not stupid so you stop playing
stupid you know now now
another piece of it is there would be
some
i'll call them labels right or kind of
buckets of this that are
not very well defined so for example uh
they're a position of perspective right
so let's say that you were a journalist
uh and you're writing about me and
you're like you know what pump's a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
i'm gonna write an article today and say
he's racist right
when you write that article your
definition
or what the evidence that you use in
your mind to rationalize racist
may actually be different than somebody
else's right and so
then there's also very clear examples of
racism
uh a perfect example is yale was
literally found guilty
of being racist towards certain
demographics
because of quotas and things like that
right that's not up for debate like that
was in a court case
et cetera and so when you look at this
it's like some people have a very
narrow defined provable view of what
racism is
other people have a different view how
do we determine like who's right and
who's wrong like it's it's a thing that
yeah webster can help us with that
uh you just go to the definition and
then if it fits in that that is racism
it has to be an
actual hatred for someone because of the
color of their skin their background
whatever
you don't get to just be like you use a
different water than me you racist
there's a joke i don't like
sexist homophobic racist like no
let's let's go back to basics and be
adults and read the dictionary and
i think it's pretty standard and i've
seen that i've seen people called racist
homophobic whatever it might be
if you're harming someone's professional
reputation
based on your opinion i don't think that
should be allowed
i think if i say i think you're an
[ __ ] okay i think you're an [ __ ]
me saying i think you're homophobic i
better have some freaking examples
showing that you hate gay people
not just it's my opinion of it because
he didn't wear a rainbow on rainbow day
you know i just think that there has to
be harsher consequences for the things
we're doing because the people who are
doing that
is the anti-bully crowd pick a [ __ ]
team
are you anti-bully anti-suicide
pro-mental health or are you trying to
cancel people you can't be both
this is where i'm at oh my favorite is
definitely the people who
uh claim to be inclusive et cetera and
then bully people on the internet
uh 100 percent yeah he's kind
he's cancelled yeah you just wrecked his
whole life be kind
those are the best um in terms of where
the solutions lie we talked a lot about
like addressing the problem
what other solutions do you feel like
are out there in terms of that
people outside of maybe kind of that
traditional media system
can do to try to solve all this comics
i think there's going to be a rise of
the comedians
in the next year and it's because
everything got so crazy everything
bubbled up
and where comics might have been more
like you know just kind of doing jokes
and whatever
everyone has to commentate now because
we're the only ones telling the truth
and the comedy that i've seen coming out
of people the last few weeks even
it's some of the best [ __ ] i've seen in
like 10 years
so i'm really excited i i think follow
your local comedians
and they're going to tell you the truth
who are your favorites to watch right
now
my favorites are a lot of my friends um
i would say jp sears is hilarious if you
like sarcasm
buddy of mine um i said a couple weeks
ago that john crist
is killing me with his videos are really
fun uh
krista stefano is awesome history hyenas
they're just
hilarious podcasts and i just think
everyone you know watch rogan
because they'll have they'll have
someone on but they'll talk about both
sides and they're not coming with an
angle on any one topic which i think is
great
and yeah what's the when you talk about
this rise
wait what i think most like a lot of
comics are great right now that are
none of like the old ones i wouldn't say
the liberal comics are great right now
i'd say the opposite
if if they're a comedian and they're
mostly being a social justice comedian
get away from that it's like all the
other ones are way better are there
bad comics right now yeah
yeah um i'd say you're not a comic if
you're doing a [ __ ] ted talk and
expecting an applause break at the end
that's not that's not comedy like if
you're trying to cancel another comedian
you're not a comedian period that guy
can say whatever he wants
lenny bruce you know like all of these
guys who came before
they were nuts in the best way possible
let let people andy kaufman if they want
to
there's no cap on comedy and anyone
who's trying to put a cap on it or say
you can't say that about anything
by get out so so where
is the voice for comics because a lot of
comics will listen to this and they'll
be like what do you mean i can't talk
about serious issues right and i put it
in air quotes because everyone's serious
issue is different
uh yeah is there a space for that or is
it only within the confines of cracking
jokes making people laugh and like kind
of
the spirit of comedians no we've always
done that comics have always like this
dude has always
you know had a speech with punch lines
in it like there's always an underlying
message for the good stuff
at least to me and yeah you can talk
about real topics
and make it funny but when there it's
it's happened a lot i saw it stand up
the last few years where there's a lot
of comedians that'll go up and just
talk about their life and everything
that's wrong and but you have to be nice
to me because i'm a pan
sexual libra hocus pocus
whatever i'm like i don't know what
you're just said i'm not clapping
because you changed your sex
that's not a joke entertaining the
audience this isn't therapy time
if it feels like therapy time i don't
want to be there you should be paying me
yeah i want to talk about censorship
in general right so i hope he likes that
definition
like that was ridiculous but anyways oh
my god i should have just used this i
have one i'm sitting right here
jesus all right so censorship
there's two types of censorship that i
think are uh well three times
three times actually so there's the
politician censorship of like you can't
do what we don't want you to do and
we're basically god and so we're gonna
you know impose our will on you there's
social media censorship
in terms of uh literally we're going to
stop you from saying things we're gonna
cut down distribution we're gonna do all
that stuff and they're doing it
frankly to all sides of the aisle uh and
then there is what i'll call just
no they're not that's only happening to
one side of the aisle
okay explain they are only
censoring conservatives and
i have not seen a single liberal
comedian censored ever
period no democrats never uh
from influencers anything only one side
is being censored that i've ever seen
so here's my pushback to this is uh if
we're talking about what i'll call
audience recognizable censorship
completely agree
right like you know my one of my
favorite examples is like literally
twitter is putting
um a like uh cover over you know
like like a disclaimer over the
president of the united uh state's
tweets
but the ccp state sponsored media
organization is on twitter saying
that the coronavirus didn't come from
wuhan and like there's no disclaimers
there's no any
like okay so we're gonna we're literally
gonna put disclaimers on the president
united states
which by the way people will debate
whether we should do that or not that's
not what i'm here to debate
what i'm here to debate is if you're
gonna do it to anybody you have to do it
to everybody
right yeah they don't of course so like
i call that like the audience
recognizable censorship right or or the
disclaimers but
whatever what i think happens though in
a very different way that is not
recognizable and it's very hard to get
data on
is they actually will change the
algorithm and distribution
and kind of all the invisible things to
all kinds of people right so if
regardless of your political view if you
go on twitter or facebook or whatever
and you say certain things
they will absolutely take distribution
away and so it's less about i'm going to
censor you because of
uh your political views or your leanings
and it's more about certain topics just
you can't talk about and i think that it
is um
what is it i think it was rogan actually
uh him or kanye one of the two of them
said like once you can't talk about a
topic
anymore now it's a religion right like
like once
you're right once it's crossed over and
so i think that's where
the censorship of both sides happens but
we just never see that right because we
don't know what people posted that we
never get
in our feeds whatever but i do agree
with you that there is a very heavy
leaning
on one side of the aisle in terms of the
audience recognizable stuff
you know so what you were saying there
is a large censorship right now
specifically on instagram
on sex workers or women who post content
with a lot of skin on it
which is not my thing uh you know this
is not my thing period
but especially right now when people are
trying to make money with their only
fans because they don't have a job
i do think it's unfair that they're only
censoring those
specific people when there's naked women
all over instagram
you know i i do see that so how do you
balance that's a perfect example how do
you balance that between like
hey we don't want nudity on our platform
and like there's kids on here right like
that type of argument right
those two things are uh in a very
overgeneralized way they're like at the
extreme ends of the angle
or of the uh of the spectrum like how do
you balance
we want to help people make money and
like not take away people's freedoms but
at the same time like we don't want
nudity and we don't want
uh you know kids to see that content
whatever and that's a weird one because
i would get not wanting kids to see
adult content but at the same time
there's 12 year olds doing tic toc
dances saying go down on me
so you know like if we're going to start
it let's start it over there
that's fair they've already seen it
they've already seen the porn we're not
we're not stopping anything yeah so
when we talk about censorship from
politicians and
the politically correct censorship like
is it just hey don't worry about it and
literally just kind of throw your
virtual middle finger up in the air and
just do the things that you want to do
that make you happy
or do you think that we're in a world
where like people still have to be
cognizant of that
and almost address it in some weird way
in what way can you expand on that
so let's take for example uh they're the
same things that instagram
you talked about like posting a certain
type of photo instagram will
decrease distribution etc if you go on
twitter
and uh chinese concentration camps right
would be like a really extreme kind of
uh thing if you go on twitter anything
yeah and you start tweeting about a
bunch of this stuff now i don't know
exactly
the way twitter would do it but i'm
saying in an example so there's
something that
uh a lot of people don't want to talk
about right but it's pretty factually
provable that hey this is happening uh
and
the platform then either through
algorithmic distribution takes it down
or literally there is social pressure
right like we saw with the nba for
example
uh and the whole china thing like there
was definitely social pressure
uh within the nba and that organization
to not talk about this to not make this
a story
how do individuals operate in that world
do they literally have to say look i
can't
be in that world i have to step outside
and literally hang my hat on being an
independent and independent thinker and
basically
say whatever i want and that's gonna be
part of my image or can people actually
operate within those confines
knowing that this stuff's going on uh no
reality can operate within those
confines but if for work purposes if
you're gonna get fired and you don't
think you can get another job
be smart do what you need to do until
you can exit to somewhere where you're
more welcomed being a whole human being
i think you know depression has gone up
anxiety's gone up suicide's going up and
it's because we're not letting people be
whole people
and think and we're lying to them to
their faces so
i saw this concentration camp this is
happening in china no it's not
that's called gaslighting we're
gaslighting mass amounts of people at
once and then wondering why we're taking
so many pills and od
and all these things everything is a
byproduct of the thing before so
i think if you're put in a circumstance
where you can't be yourself you got to
get yourself out of there at least
create an
you know an action plan for an exit plan
uh
we have to be whole people or we're not
happy people that's my thought on that
all right before i get into the rapid
fire to wrap this up i have one
question liar okay and i i've been
thinking all day as to what you're gonna
answer and i literally have no clue but
if you were president for one day
and you could do whatever you wanted
what are the things you would do first
oh my gosh president for one day okay
well snowden he's good
you're good snowden um like that's near
the top
uh can i use my martial law no
my things aoc you're gone you just gotta
go i would clean if i could if i could
make my own laws for one day and i'm
like king of the world style president
the whole squad they gotta go they're
too stupid to be participating in
politics
period if there's anyone on the other
side that's that dumb two
they gotta go you can't sell a
sweatshirt for 65 that says tax the rich
you are a dumb person um i don't know if
you saw those ones
i i saw they changed the price to 58 i
saw
oh yeah that's still a giant margin
where's that money going anyway
uh we know that sweatshirt cost eight
bucks max
um yeah i would definitely i got one day
okay one day i would tell texas they're
doing a great job
i would tell la you guys are nuts you
got to open small but
if it was right now i would open all the
small businesses i'd be like no
wear a mask wash your hands do the
things you're supposed to do
we cannot tank all of these people's
livelihoods
because of a virus with a survival rate
of 90 whatever percent
if you are scared stay home and you guys
are the ones who get the subsidies
we're gonna give the subsidies to this
you know the people who are most
affected
that makes more sense to me um i'm like
one day
i would do this to china um i would stop
letting them
i would set up rules and regulations so
they're not going to be buying
more property in canada and america i
tell justin trudeau to [ __ ] himself
um what's your problem with him what's
not my problem with him
let's just boil it down to one like just
other than the fact that he suddenly
talks like a robot and it's really
creepy
um months ago all these
tons of air canada planes were coming
from china at the beginning of the
pandemic
tweeting him i'm like hey hey maybe we
don't want those planes coming in
from luhan directly nothing
five six planes coming in every day i
don't know why it's spreading in canada
i'm like hey man maybe maybe don't let
more planes land from wuhan
that's racist no it's not look at the
definition of racism
morons 20 more planes come in and then
suddenly it's like oh maybe we should
stop letting planes from china
like it's just such basic [ __ ] i don't
understand how they don't do it
and i just think he's done a horrible
job during this entire pandemic
i just i just think i would have voted
for him at the beginning i did vote for
him before
but now he's just shown that he can't
handle pressure
all right i have a follow-up question
now okay what is the politician that you
think has done the best job during all
of this
dan crenshaw why um
he he's someone i would go to for news
dan
is so stoic and you know i think it's
that seal background that he has where
he's just gonna tell it how it is as it
is deal with the reality of it
and that's it and he cares about facts
he will put up
what's real what's not what you know a
celebrity said what the reality of it is
and i just like that he stays chill i
can trust him
and i like that you do realize that most
people who are listening to this who
have any sort of left leaning are their
minds are blown right now that you are a
lifeline democrat
who now supported trump and thinks that
dan crenshaw has handled
this the best that's okay their minds
can be blown
that's okay of course you know i think
it's really
what was really weird to me was seeing
people who are like kind and tolerant
whatever
let's say jonathan van ness for example
from queer eye for the straight guy
he went on a live stream the day before
the election and i i'm a fan i watched
him
and he said anyone who votes for trump
is a racist
and homophobic that's half of america
and that's just not true
and putting that into people's heads is
freaking criminal that's that's mind
rape i don't like it
that's a lie and i actually helped
organize world pride
multiple times i was on a float standing
next to jonathan van ness
in pride in la a year ago i'm not
homophobic
but you just told me i am like it's just
such lunacy i just can't play anymore so
if they start realizing how silly they
sound i'm cool with that be nice people
that's it i think that's a fair way to
to view the world
all right two questions to wrap up and
you get asked me one uh first
what's what's the most important book
you've ever read
um the alchemist why uh
i love the way it shows you how
everything in your life happens for a
reason the hard stuff the good stuff
everything and it all circles back to
why you're here
there's just a lot of good lessons in it
and yeah
it's great answer uh second question is
more fun aliens are you a believer or
non-believer
yeah of course i'm a believer are you
kidding me why
come on ancient because aliens ancient
aliens
um yeah that's my answer to everything
just look
i've had weird experiences in my life
but you know just like did you see an
alien
i haven't seen an alien per se but i've
definitely seen craft
and i've seen weird things in the sky
multiple times i used to have a real
crazy
aliens when i was kids when i was a kid
i'd have it like every night for
whatever but i just look at like the
structures in the world i look at
you know energy coming from crystals i
look at
how did suddenly we have these crazy ass
weapons
are you hold on hold on jump timeout
this is important
are you one of these crazy crystal
people who has a bunch of crystals
laying around their house because it has
good energy
i have like two giant i have a skull
right here
dude it's quantum physics bring it back
to science you get thr you get 30
seconds to explain
the uh absolute craziness around
crystals
i recently learned about this you get 30
seconds explain it okay well for
craziness around crystals come on um
okay dude
what do we use to make lasers how do
lasers cut
crystals crystals are used in every
major weapon
in the world they're used in surgeries
they're used in all sorts of things
uh for us to pretend that there isn't
power and crystals is actually kind of
silly
it you know it that's the what does the
crystal do by having it sit there what
does it do
it depends what it is so it it's just
like that one the one you just held it
up
you just held up a crystal in the shade
give it to me by a fan yeah
um this one i believe it's just like
it's just good vibes and makes it chill
but there's different vibrations just
like everything is energy there's
different
vibrations in us having these headphones
in our ears and anything
uh it just changes vibrations around you
and that's
that's the easiest way to do it and then
you can turn it into lasers
yeah all right that's fair you could ask
me one question to finish up what you
got for me
what do you invest in the most uh
bitcoin by far
okay that was an easy answer and that
was easy i only have
one investment philosophy which is
basically this idea that
uh innovation drives returns and so
basically look for
the farthest thing away from the center
mass
of the investing world uh so if everyone
else likes you know i like domestic tech
stocks like okay well that's stupid
like just go as far away from the the
center as possible
and look for the things on the fringe
where uh innovation is
highly asymmetric meaning that uh it has
a low probability of working but if it
works it will be
off the charts in terms of the return
profile uh
and then put multiple bets on the table
and what you basically end up doing
is you're looking for the power law to
take over so venture capital is a
perfect example of this
give money to a bunch of small
entrepreneurial teams let them go
literally try
to work every day to grow your money uh
bitcoins is a very similar thing it
doesn't have a corporation or company
behind it but it's basically an
innovative piece of technology that
thousands of people around the world are
working on to uh to make successful so
that's like pretty simple strategy the
hard part is finding people that fit
within it
sweet well i listened to you and i
invested in grayscale so bitcoin via
grayscale
and i told you i did a hundred thousand
dollars in two and a half weeks so it's
not that bad
i'm not mad at it uh you shouldn't be
mad at that if uh if those are the
returns you're getting
uh where can we send people to find you
on the internet uh
and find all your content on twitter i'm
nicole arbour with the you you know
canada
uh instagram is letter i letter b nicole
arbour
nicole arbor fans on facebook just type
nicole arbour everywhere on parlor i'm
nicole arbour
yeah where where's the one place if you
send everyone you want them to go
instagram instagram all right yeah and
it's nicole arbour on instagram
i be nicole arbour what oh i
okay got it someone stole my name out of
principle i wouldn't give them 30 000 to
get it back i refuse uh that's fair
that's fine all right thank you for
doing this we'll do it again in the
future yeah thanks for having me
go team